So the cycles, per instruction, we spent in the
pipe line should be one once we have filled
our pipe line. Note that we have building instructions
to process in a program usually. So the first
few cycles are negligible, we can just ignore them
and say that in the steady state we're just
finishing one instruction every cycle. Is that true, however?
So the reasons why we don't always get the flow
rate of one are the initial filling of
the pipeline. But even with the initial fill, the
CPI will get closer and closer to one
as the number of instructions grows, and because we
have many, many instructions this is not really
a big problem. Our CPI could be set to
be one in spite of this. The CPI in the steady state is not one also because
of pipeline stalls. Think about, for example, a car
production line where the first stage is to install the
doors. The second stage is to install front wheels,
the next stage is to install the rear wheels and
there are many more stages. And let's say that
at some point we have a black car here, with
the front wheels already installed, a purple car here, waiting
to install the front wheels and the green car here,
still without the doors. It's installing the doors. Let's
say that during the installation of the front wheels here,
the machine damages the wheel. So now what happens
is when the production line can move on because the
rear wheels have been installed on the black car,
the black car can move on to the next stage,
and it has the rear wheels installed,. But we don't
want to move the purple car here because it still
doesn't have the front wheels. If we let that happen
we'll end up with a car that has no front
wheels. So the purple cars will stay in this install
front wheels stage for one more cycle to have a new
set of wheels installed. Because the purple car didn't move
on, the worker over here is idle because there is
no car to install the rear wheels in this cycle
and because the purple car didn't move on, the green car,
whose doors have been installed, cannot move on. So
we have an idle stage here, too. Let's say that
the wheels are correctly installed this time here. Now the
purple car moves on. The next stage of the pipeline,
however, gets to do nothing because no car has moved
on. The green car will now move here. And we
will begin a new car here for installing the doors.
So the problem is that when the black car leaves
the pipeline there will be one car worth of
time where we don't finish car and only then
the purple car will come. So every one of
these breaks in the pipeline, that stall the pipeline, it
cannot move on, will result in not finishing a
car, when a car should have been finished. If
these stalls happen on a regular basis, the CP,I
will not be one, it will be lower than one.
For example, if every five cars we have this, then really takes, six cycles to
finish five cars. So the CPI is six cycles over five cars, and we end up
with a CPI of 1.2 not one. So even the steady state pipeline CPI will
be larger than one, meaning we don't finish
an instruction every cycle because of pipeline stalls.
So we have seen how a stall can happen in
a car pipeline because of broken wheels or something. But
in a processor pipeline how can it be that we
have a stall? So what goes broken with an instruction?